[موسيقى]
من العربيه لكم من كل التحيه هذه اخبار
المساء وانا ريما مكتبي نبدا بابرز
العناوين
و رونالدو
[تصفيق]
تحت مظله نيته وللمره الاولى منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه القوه الجويه الامريكيه
101 تناول على اعتاب روسيا
امام الكونغرس منقسم والجمهوريون يتوعدونه
بقائمه تحقيقات جنائيه ومدنيه
في بريطانيا القطارات مشلوله بسبب الاضراب
وقطاع الصحه ينازع ويطالب السكان بان لا
يمرضوا
[موسيقى]
قدم نادي النصر السعودي نجمه الجديد
كريستيانو رونالدو في ملعب مرسول بارك في
حفل حضره 30 الف متفرج وخلال المؤتمر
الصحفي لتقديم الصفقه الاسطوريه قال
رونالدو انه اختار نادي النصر رغم العروض
الاوروبيه التي قدمت له
واكد صاروخ انا الدوري السعودي يتميز
بتنافسها كبيره معربا عن تطلعه بالمشاركه
في المباراه القادمه اذا قرر المدرب ذلك
واضاف النجم البرتغالي انه يسعى لتحطيم
الارقام القياسيه مع النصر مضحا انه جاء
للفوز وللمشاركه في ثقافه النادي والبلد
توماتيكو
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من ملعب مرسول الباركس فهد
الشهري مراسل العربيه فهد اهلا بك همم 30
الف شخص حضروه هذا الاحتفال
وبصراحه الصفقا عقدت خلال يومين فقط يعني
تحضر الجميع للحضور باخر لحظه كيف كانت
اجواء الملعب لا زالت مستمره والتدريبات
مستمره صف لنا المشهد من حولك
30,000 كما تعلم ويعلم سعد المشاهدين انه
الملعب يتسع ل 25,000 فقط لكن تم فتح
البوابات في اللحظات الاخيره لمن لم يحمل
تذاكر وما يستطيع الملعب استيعابه العدد
كان اكبر بكثير خارج الملعب من مكانه
يتمنون او يرغبون في مشاهده هذا الحفل
الاسطوري لتقديم الاسطوره كريستيانو
رونالدو اللي راح يمثل نادي النصر لمده
موسم بعد زي ما قلتي مفاوضات استمرت
اليومين في اسبانيا بعد وفق اللاعب القدوم
السعوديه وتجروا وتجربه تحدي جديد للحفل
جميل كما تشاهدين لازال المشجعين يستمتعون
بمشاهده كريستال رونالدو وهو لاعب كره
القدم لاول مره في الملاعب السعوديه تحت
اشراف في المدرب رودي غورسيا مدرب نادي
النصر اللي اعتقد انه الان قاعد يراقب
جاهزيه الكابتن همم كريستيانو رونالدو
بتقول للزج به في المباريات القادمه بعد
وصول بطاقه من الفيفا حفل كان جميل حفل
كان يليق بمناسبه لجميع اشاد به كان في
وسائل الاعلام كبيره من خارج المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ادهلوا عبده اعجابهم بما
شاهدوه في هذا الحفل الكبير جدا فعلا فهد
حفل يليق بالسعوديه طيب هل هي صفقه بي ار
او علاقات عامه همم انه فعلا سيلعب همم مع
الفريق يعني اكيد سيلعب ولكن همم الجميع
يسال هل هي فقط في ار او فقط للاعلان على
الموضوع
لا بعد ارتداد تيشيرت النصر اليوم من
كريستيانو رونالدو خلاص دخل المشجع اللي
كان يحلم انه كريستيانو او المتابع لي كان
يحلى من كريستيانو يمثل في الكره السعوديه
وفي النصر التحديد دخل الى عالم الواقع
واللي يعرف كريستيانو في كل محطاته هو
رياضي ضخم قبل ما يكون لاعب كره قدم يعشق
التحديات هو قالها بلساني انا حطمت ارقام
كبيره في اوروبا وجاي وحاضر للسعوديه كي
يصنع التاريخ اللاعب جاهز اللاعب فقط
ينتظره وصول بطاقه من الفيفا واسقاط
الاجنبي الثامن في نادي النصر حتى يتمكن
ومشاهدته لاعبا في فريق سعوديا في دوري
روشن السعودي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا اصبحت على
خارطه اللاعبين دوليين همم في كره القدم
هل في معلومات عن صفقات اخرى تجري او
مشاورات مع بين كبار اخرين لفرق ثانيه مثل
الهلال او غيره
قدوم كريستيانو كما تشاهدين ولا نتدرب في
الاراضي السعوديه ما كان اصلا اسم
كريستيانو او اللاعبين كريستيانو وكان حلو
منه نشاهدهم يتمرن اليوم الان امامنا امام
الجمهور السعودي امام الوسائل الاعلام
السعوديه كريستيانو رونالدو
ويعيدها مره اخرى الغنام هي البدايه قدهم
كريستيانو رونالدو سيسمح لاي نادي سعودي
وهذا ما اتوقع مستقبلا للمفاوضه اي اسم
اذا كان كريستيانو رونالدو
وبطولاتي وبكل ما قدمه في عالم كره القدم
اليوم نوقع لنادي النصر نادي كبير في
السعوديه فهذا سيفتح
ويمسح جمله انه مستحيل قدوم اي نجم او اي
رياض كبير في كره القدم او غير كره القدم
هذه السعوديه هذه رؤيه 2030
استندت على هذا الشيء انه نشاهد مثل
كريستيانو رونالدو وغير كرستيانو رونالدو
يلعبون في كره القدم هذا ما توقعوا اتوقع
مشاهده اكثر من نجم يضاه هون كريستيانو
رونالدو في الاسم المستوى في الفرق
السعوديه ابتداءا من الصيف القادم
اذا امكن للكاميرا ان تورينا رونالدو وهو
يلعب على الاراضي السعوديه في صوره
تاريخيه بعالم كره القدم وعالم الرياضه
وانا هنا ايضا سؤالي بموضوع الهلال اين
اين مشجعين الهلال همم هل هو شعور انه هذا
انجاز للسعوديه ام انها تحجب للفرق
الرياضيه هو طاغي يعني انا عارف بعض الناس
كمان مش عاجبني الموضوع ولكن مبسوطين
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
له قدوم رونالدو فرحه للجميع يعني اعتقد
قدوم رونالدو تتابعوا تابعه تحديات وتابع
اعتراضات وحتى على الحكم كل شيء من
كريستيانو رونالدو والنجوم اللي ماسك
كريستيانو رونالدو مقبول ومنتظر هشام وجه
الكاميرا الكرستيانو رونالدو كمان تشاهدون
كريستيانو رونالدو الان في وسط اللاعبين
هنا كريستيانو رونالدو
تحدي بين جمهور النصر والهلال تحدي
ازلي تحدي كبير
كريستيانو
هذا امر طبيعي لكن في المجمل الملعب اليوم
كان ممتله كمان تماما ايضا الشوارع والطرق
كان هناك ترحيب كبير المشجعين الرياضيين
اللي محايدين لا نصر والهلال عبده
واعجابهم من الصفقه وهذا هو المنتظر لكن
اكيد ان الهلالي بنسبه كبيره انه لا يعني
ما كنت اتمنى انه كريستيانو رونالدو
يمثل الناس وهذا امر طبيعي ولو كان العكس
وكمان
نصراوي ما راح يتمنى ههه
انه يشوفهم في نادي الهلال او نادي غيره
جدا عقبال اللاعبين الكبار يكون ايضا على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه رقم سبعه هو رقم
رونالدو وراينا يلعب في التدريبات تاريخيه
على ارض الرياض في صفقه مهمه جدا في عالم
كره القدم وهذه المشاهد مباشره من مرسول
بارك في الرياض بعد حفل ااه اعلان انضمام
كريستيانو رونالدو لفريق النصر
صفقات تاريخيه
وطبعا عين المجتمع الدولي الرياضي في عالم
الرياضه على المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد
هذه الصفقه شكرا فهد الشهري مراسل العربيه
كان معنا من مرسول بارك شكرا جزيلا لك
واعد الى ضيف او انتقل الى ضيف ايضا في
الرياض محمد الغامدي الاعلامي الرياضي
محمد اهلا بك هناك برجصه من الاسماء يتم
الحديث عنها في
سياق طموحات المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان
تكون في نادي كبار الدول بالمشهد الرياضي
من هي هذه البورصه برايك ما الاسماء التي
ممكن ان تاتي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
للهلال او الفرق الثانيه
قبل الحديث عن
اللاعبين القادمين لابد ان نؤكد ان هذا
الحدث يمثل حدث اضخم في العالم
لا يقل درجه عن حدث كاس العالم ليقيم في
قطر ولذلك همم العالم باكمله يتحدث عن
الحدث الرياضي بقدوم كريستيانو رونالدو
الى المملكه وتحديدا نادي النصر الحقيقه
نادي النصر داب من سنوات طويله على جلب
كثير من اللاعبين العالميين بدا في عام 78
ميلادي توتنه البرازيلي لاعب المنتخب
البرازيلي مرورا في عام 98 او ما قبلها 94
دي نيلسون مرورا في 98 البرتغالي
اذا نحن امام نادي يجلب الكثير من
اللاعبين البارزين نظرا لقوه الدعم المالي
الذي يضخه اعضاء شرف نادي النصر من بار
همم
الاغنياء في همم العاصمه وغيرها لذلك نجد
ان همم نادي النصر اليوم محظوظ بقدوم مثل
هذا النجم الكبير اولا للقيمه الفنيه
والقيمه الاعلاميه التي يتمتع فيها هذا
اللاعب نعرف ان من خلال شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي الارقام الفلكيه التي
ظهرت في قدوم هذا اللاعب منذ كاس العالم
والاحاديث تتحدث عن نادي النصر وقدوم هذا
اللاعب فيما يخص اللاعبين القادمين حقيقه
لا اعلم ولكن المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والرياضه السعوديه بالذات اخذت بعد كبير
خلال السنوات الخمس الماضيه في الاهتمام
همم الان همم لدينا اكثر من حوالي 90
اتحاد رياضي بعد ان كان هناك نحو 20 اتحاد
فقط فاذا من خلال خمس سنوات الماضيه همم
تنوعت الالعاب المختلفه في المملكه
زاد استضافه الاحداث والفعاليات لعله الان
وانا احدد لك في هناك حدث عالمي كبير وهو
بطوله الرالي دكار اذا نحن امام همم حراك
رياضي كبير همم يقام في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نادي النصر يمثل ذلك
ثمنها فلوس وعقود ولكن ماذا تريد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه نادي النصر او غيره
بالبروفايل الرياضي اين تريد ان تصل
السعوديه على يعني الساحل الرياضيه برايك
اسمحي لي اختلف معك في ان هذا هذه الصفقه
تكون تجاريه فقط وانا سمعت سؤالك الزميل
المراسل فهد الشهري بانها قد تكون صفقه بي
ار قد تكون هذا الجانب مهم ولكن لا ننسى
ان لاعب بقيمه وقامت رونالدو لا زال محتفظ
بكامل جاهزيه الفنيه والبدنيه بدليل
الحديث وفي المؤتمر الصحفي عندما اشار
انني رهن اشاره المدرب عندما العب
المباراه القادمه يوم الخميس امام الطائي
هذا معناه ان اللاعب يحتفظ بكل الجاهزيه
الفنيه والبدنيه رغم غيابه عن المباريات
منذ كاس العالم نحن شهر اذا نحن امام لاعب
جميع سلوكياته جميع اهتمامه ينصب على ان
يكون لاعب كبير
نحن نسال كل الاسئله التي يتم تداولها
بهذا الموضوع واتحدث عن البي ار لانه في
كثير من لاعبين هذه الايام يشاركون بحملات
دعائيه اعلانيه على الشاشات ميسي بكثير من
الدعايات همم العلاقه بالمنطقه بالشرق
الاوسط وبالتالي في رد ايضا من اللاعبين
العالميين على الشرق الاوسط بهذا الموضوع
اين تريد ان تصل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالساحه الرياضيه ما هي طموحات
القياده السياسيه خلال السنوات الست
الماضيه همم وضعت الرياضه عنوان كبير في
التنميه وبالتالي اصبحت الرياضه في مختلف
العابها تحظى باهتمام ودعم متزايد لعلنا
الان في دوري روشن يعتبر الدوله السعودي
من ضمن اكثر عشر دوريات في العالم
فبالتالي انا همم اؤكد ان الابعاد التي
فيها التعاقد مع اللاعب قد تكون ابعاد يا
اعلاميه رياضيه ترويجيه سياحيه ولكن لا
ننسى ان هذا اللاعب رغم بلوغه 37 سنه
يحتفظ بكل قيمته الفنيه بدليل اليوم
الحضور الجماهيري
والعدد الكبير الذي كان في انتظار الحصول
على التذاكر التي انت تخيل ان النحو
100,000 في الانتظار في مرسول البار
الاخير الكره القدم هي لعبه يحلم بها
الشاب اول عمره واحيانا يعني يصلون الى
النجوميه هي حلم لدى البعض
رونالدو مجيء رونالدو الان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى اي مدى يؤثر على
الجيل الشباب في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كيف يلهم الجيل الجديد برايك بعالم رياضه
بلا شك احد العناوين الرئيسيه همم جذب
النشا الى كره القدم وبالتالي للاسماء
التي لها قيمه همم رونالدو هو ملهم الكثير
من الناشئين اليوم الحضور في ملعب مرصول
بارك يمكن يصل الى اكثر من 60% من من
الجماهير التي اعمارها من عشر سنوات الى
20 سنه فبالتالي هذا اللاعب هو يعتبر قدوه
بحكم سلوكياته الجميله التي يتمتع بها
بحكمه اهتمامه واحترافيه الكبيره لا زال
يحفظ هذا التوهج الكبير
ايضا ينافسنا على الساحه الدوليه
والعالميه وايضا يعني يتم شرائهم من انديه
عالميه كبيره شكرا جزيلا لك كان معي من
الرياض سيد محمد الغامدي الاعلامي الرياضي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
لاول مره وعلى بعد امتار من ساحه الحرب في
اوكرانيا تجري الفرقه 101 الجويه
الامريكيه وتحت مظله الناتو تدريبات
ومنورات عسكريه في رومانيا الفرقه 101
المحموله جوا او كما تلقب بفرقه النسور
الصاخبه الامريكيه كانت قد اعادت انتشارها
باوروبا لاول مره منذ 80 عاما تحديدا بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه لتبدو هذه المره
اقرب من اي وقت مضى من الحرب في اوكرانيا
الفرقه القتاليه هذه اتخذت من قاعده للجيش
الروماني وهي قريبه من البحر الاسود مركزا
لها ونقطه انطلاق لاي عمليه عسكريه محتمله
للدفاع عن دول النيترو في حال اي تهديد
سينما الخاسره الشرقيه للحلف
نشر هذه القوات في رومانيا يعد بمثابه
تحذير لموسكوكا جزء من تعهد الرئيس
بالدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضي نيته واجرؤ
تدريبات مشتركه هو وسيله لضمان استعداد
الحلفاء في جنوب شرق اوروبا للبقاء على
الخط
هي اجمالا 4700 جندي من القوه 101
المحموله جوا تم نشرهم في اوروبا خصوصا
برومانيا لتعزيز الجناح الشرقي لحلف
النيته وتامينه من اي هجوم الروسيه
المحتمل مستقبلا نشر الفرقه 101 هذه لها
اهداف ابعد من اوكرانيا وروسيا فهي الفرقه
الامريكيه تستخدمه البحر الاسود للتدريب
على دفاع الساحلي وهي مهاره وهي مهاره
مفيده اذا فكرت الصين بغزه تايوان وهي
جزيره وسط البحر لكن التركيز الان وفقا
المعلن هو مراقبه الحرب باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مين هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في سمائي اوكرانيا الايراني
خلالها عفوا اليومين الاولين من العام
الجديد زنسكي شدد على ضروره امداد بلاده
بانظمه دفاعيه متطوره اضافه الى مسيرات
قتاليه تصد مسيرات موسكو المتفجره في الجو
معي من موسكو عبرا سكايب بابل
المحلل العسكري اهلا بك سيد فاضل اعاده
تموضع القوات قوات النيته على مداخل همم
روسيا بهذا الشكل هل هو ايضا اعاده همم
خلط الاوراق بالنسبه لي موازين القوى بين
روسيا والغرب
موقع فريزر
الى رومانيا هي بالشكل الاساسي الاساسي
انسحبت
من
الضفه الغربيه خيرسون
مارجرج
بعد استغله على الجسر في مارس لا يوجد اي
تهديد حقيقي لتحرك القوات الروسيه الى
مولدوفا او الى حدودي رومانيا
[موسيقى]
لصدام بين امريكا وروسيا وربما يخسروا ذلك
بين القوات الروسيه
والقوات
الامريكيه مباشره بين روسيا وامريكا
تتصاعد
الى مرحله
الامريكيه همم لاعاده تعزيزي موقتها امامي
ليس الذي يثقل مباشر
بريمي
القوات الاوكرانيه وروسيا
روسيا اذا كان هذا
يقول ان الترسانه النوويه جاهزه بنسبه 91%
قالها قبل ايام والغرب يرد باعاده موضع
القوات تاب ولا احد يريد حرب عالميه
الثالثه كما فهمنا من بدايه الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا طيب اليس هناك خطر من
حرب الخطا اكسنت الورد
ورده
منخرطه في هذه المعركه روسيا في حاله حرب
وهي قوى نوويه خارقه والولايات المتحده
ايضا القوه نوويه
وقواتها مباشره
ليفربول
تدمير الطرف الاخر وهذا يعني بنماسكو على
ارجع لن تفعل ذلك
التهديد باستخدام القوه النوويه
هذا هو الغرض الرئيسي من بناء القوه
شكرا جزيلا لك انا معي من موسكو عبرا
سكايب المحلل العسكري بافل ذلك
اتهموهم بتجاهل المخاطر مع تصاعدي حده
الغضب على خلفيه مقتل عشرات الجنود الروس
في واحده من اجمل ضربات خلال الحرب وذلك
بعد تدمير ثقنا كامله للجيش الروسي فيما
كيفكا بدونيسيا
[موسيقى]
الضغط الاوكراني على ارض المعركه يتوقفوا
على شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه التي سيتم
ارسالها الى كيف في الاشهر المقبله وفي
وقت لا تزال مقاتلات
الامريكيه ضمن قائمه الاسلحه المطلوبه
شملت القائمه خطوط حمراء
ودبابات قتال حديثه
الروسيه
ومستودعات الاسلحه من نطاق
بطاريات هاي مارس
معسكرات معسكرات الجنود الروس ونقاط
تمركزهم بقيت في نطاق مرمى صواريخ هاي
مارس ودليل على فعاليتها سقوط عشرات
الجنود الروس في دوناتس في اربع صواريخ من
طراز هاي مارس
هذه التحركات والنتائج الايجابيه على
الميدان زادت الدعوات الاوكرانيه لتزويدهم
بصواريخ
وهي اطول مده من نظراتها هاي مارس والتي
يمكنها التحليق طويلا بقطعها مسافه تتجاوز
190 ميلان قبل ان تصيب الهدف بدقه
[موسيقى]
وتتابعونا في نشره المساء ايضا
بعد اقتحام بن غفير ان المسجد الاقصى
واشنطن ولندن تاكدان الحفاظ على الوضع
القائم في الاماكن المقدسه في القدس
[موسيقى]
اليوم الجمهوريون رئاسه مجلس النواب في
الولايات المتحده لكن يتعين عليهم
الجمهوريين اولا التغلب على الخلافات داخل
صفوفهم بعد ان ادى اليمين
قدمين والتي تتمثل بصعوبه الاتفاق على
انتخاب الزعيم لهم كرئيس لمجلس النواب وهو
امر تعوقه حتى الان على الانقسامات القويه
في صفوف الحزب رغم ترشيحهم كفن مقاسي
للمنصب وللمره الاولى منذ تنصيبه سيتعين
على بيض التعامل مع برلمان منقسم فقد
احتفظ حزبه الديمقراطي بالسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ لكن المعارضه الجمهوريه فازت بغلبه
جدا في مجلس النواب
ومع امتلاكي الجمهوريين الغالبيه في مجلس
النواب لن يتمكن بيض وديمقراطيون من تمرير
مشاريع كبرى جديده والوضع مماثل في مجلس
الشيوخ للغالبيه الديمقراطيه حيث لا يمتلك
الجمهوريون الكلمه الفصل لكن مسؤولين
امريكيين يخشون انتهاء عصر التعاون بين
الحزبين مع توقع دخول العمليه التشريعيه
طريق مسدود فيما يتوعد الجمهوريون باجند
التحقيقات صارمه في معظم جوانب اداره
الرئيس جوبادل
[موسيقى]
كويس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا معارك طاحنه تدور في اروقه الكونغرس
بين الجمهوريين حول انتخاب النائب كفن
بكارسي لخلافه نانسي فالوزي لرئاسه مجلس
النواب بعد فوزهم الضئيل في انتخابات
الكونغرس النصفيه نتابع القصه
للجمهوريين لكن البدايه تعثرت فالرجل
الطامح في منصب نانسي فلوسي كرئيس
للاغلبيه في مجلس النواب لم يضمن الرقم
السحري وهو 2818
مفاوضات خلف الابواب المغلقه في اللحظات
الاخيره في محاولات لتفادي اجراء جوله
اعاده التصويت على اهم منصب للجمهوريين
استردوهم من ناس بلوشي حيث لم يتم التصويت
على اختراع الاعاده منذ 100 عام كان هدف
عام
هذه الخلافات تمطر بعواصف وانقسامات بين
صفوف وكوادر الحزب الجمهوري للسنوات
القادمه
هاي هاي
في حزب الجمهوريه الجميع يعتبر نفسه
محافظا لكن السؤال هو اي نوع من المحافظين
هناك مثلا ما يسمى بتجمع الحريه وهم
الاكثر موالاه لدونالد ترامب داخل الحزب
وهم يعرضون مكارث وعندما تكون هناك اغلبيه
باربعه اصوات لا يمكن انتخابه بامتناع
السته نوابنا من حسبه
[تصفيق]
انشغال الجمهوريين بمعركه رئاسه الكونجرس
وتاخرهم عن فتح لجان تحقيق وعد بها سواء
كانت في الخروج الذي وصف بالمهين لاداره
بيض من افغانستان او ملفاته هانتر وعلاقته
مع شركات صينيه او حتى صلاحيات الرئيس
لاداره البلاد
[موسيقى]
خلافاتهم فعل الرئيس التعامل مع كونغرس
المنقسم لاول مره ولم يستطيع تمريرا
مشاريع كبرى كما فعل على مدى العامين
السابقين لكننا خلافات الجمهوريين تثلج
صدر الرئيس والديمقراطيين في القاهره
ينضم الينا من واشنطن دكتور وليد فارس
الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
دكتور وليد اهلا بك هذه مشاهد مباشره
لعمليه التصويت الان في الكونغرس الامريكي
في اول جلسه له ااا منذ اجراء الانتخابات
وحتى اللحظه مقارسي حصل على 20 صوت معارض
هو يحتاج الى 218 صوت همم على ما اعتقد
ولا شك انه عمليه بار يعني يعملها همم
كرسي لاقناع اعضاء حزب الجمهوريه هلا ما
هي الخيارات دكتور وليد يعني اليوم قد لا
يصل الى رئاسه همم اذا الى هذا الموقع
كارسي ما هي الخيارات الدم وما هي الاليه
هنالك مساله رقميه هنالك معارضه في الحزب
الجمهوري لقياده مكارتي للكونجرس ولكن هذه
المعارضه عندها قدره واحده انه ان تعطل
انتخابه هو يحتاج هذه الاصوات
لكي يتمكن من ان يتفوق على الديمقراطيين
يعني يتفرجون على الوضع ولكن بنهايه
المطار هذه الاصوات السته وهم من المجموعه
مجموعه الفرقس غير قادرين ان يرشحوا شخصا
اخر يحصل على كل الاصوات الضروريه اذا
وكانها كانوا جناح يضغط على مكارته ويضغط
وقد يقبل هذا الجناح بان تكون هنالك عده
جلسات لكي يتم اختياره بنهايه المطار ولكن
ماذا يبون ان تكون لهم شروط افضل للجاه
همم دكتور وليد اولا لنرى المشاهد من داخل
الكونغرس في بعض اعضاء الكونجرس جلب
واولاده معهم واضح انه ما في بيبي سترز من
المشاهد المميزه اللي بنشوفها بالعالم
الغربي للبرلمانات مشاهد مهمه جدا يعني
برايي دكتور وليد همم هناك نوع من
المقايضه في تنازلات على ماي كراسي ان
يقدمها ماذا يريد هؤلاء يعني ما هي
التنازلات التي عليها ان يقدمها ليصل الى
الموقع
منها ما هو معروف ما يرى وما لا يرى كما
يقال ما هي معروفه هي قيادات بعض اللجان
ما هي غير معروفه مبادرات سوف تطلقها هذه
الاقليه ضمن الحزب الجمهوري تكون متشدده
جدا مع الطرف الاخر منها عمليه يعني كشف
عن ملفات معينه قد لا يكون مكارتي مستعد
يقول لهم اذا انا اتيت كرئيس لهذا
البرلمان لهذا الهوس يعني بقيه الممثلين
عمل لارضاء الشعب الامريكي و20% امور
سياسيه فتح ملفات ابن الرئيس ملفات
افغانستان الى ما هنالك هم يحاولون
التفاوض على من الملفات سوف يسمح لهم ان
يفتحوها والميزانيه
ما هي الملفات التي ينتظر الجمهوريون
الفرصه لفتحها غير همم موضوع ابن همم
وهل يصلون النتائج نتيجه موضوع افغانستان
فضيحه يعني صوره امريكا بالعالم كلها تهزت
بعدها المشاهد للطياره عم يسقط منها الناس
هذه هي المرحله التي سوف يكون هناك
محاسبات على الاقل محاسبات سياسيه
واعلاميه سوف تتمكن الاكثريه الجمهوريه
ومعهم بعض اعضاء الكتله الديمقراطيه لانه
مش كل الديمقراطيين كانوا يؤيدون هذا
الوضع لفتح الملفات بما معناه سيطلبوا من
البانتجون من مجلس الامن القوم يعني كل
شيء عملوا الديمقراطيين
بالجمهوريين سوف همم يرد جمهوريون ولكن
موضوع افغانستان قريب على قلوب كثير من
الامريكيين من عائلات الامريكيه من الذين
خدموا على مده 20 سنه هذا ما نفسه سوف
يكون دسم وقاسي وبيح كما يقال بالنسبه
للجمهوريه ملاس في الاخر الاكبر ولكن ليس
هنالك معلومات كثيره حوله هو ما كانت شروط
التفاوض بين اداره اوباما يعني عم نحكي عن
2015 والنظم الايراني
لا تزال تطبق هذه المفاهيم او زي الشروط
التي لا يعرفها الكثير من اعضاء الكونجرس
الموجود على راس هذه المفاوضات ايضا من
جديد دكتور وليد لا يمل في كثير من الامور
بنحب نفتحها معك لكن الوقت دهمنا من
واشنطن دكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اكدت كل من واشنطن رافضهما اي تغيير في
الوضع القائم في الاماكن المقدسه في القدس
وذلك ردا على اقتحام الوزير الاسرائيلي
المتشدد اثمار بين غفير المسجد الاقصى
وذلك للمره الاولى منذ تواليها الاسبوع
الماضي منصبه في حكومتناهم
على واقع الاقتحام الاستفزازي لوزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بنج فير مساحات المسجد
الاقصى سرعت اسرائيل الى رفع حاله التاهب
خاصه على حدود قطاع غزه خشيه من اطلاق
صواريخ وخوفا من عدم اختصار ردود الفعل
الشعبي والرسميه الفلسطينيه على بيانات
التمديد والاستنكار الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
يرضى بتمرير هذه الجرائم اليوميه من
اقتحامات للاقصى وكانت الاقتحامات تتم على
يد المستوطنين الان تتم اعياد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يعني
يضع قواعد جديده للعبه في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وانا اقول انه سيتحمل المسؤوليه
عن نتائج هذه اللعبه لان اللاعب بالمسجد
الاقصى المبارك هو بالعدل عبر النار
بالتجربه منذ عام 67 وحتى اللحظه وكان
الوزير المتطرف بين كبير لجا الى نوع من
الخدعه حيث اشعه ان اقتحامه الاقصى تاجل
بعد تحفظ نتنياهو لكن الرجلين كانت اتفق
على الاقتحام مسبقا
تم مده 13 دقيقه فقط بشكل غير معلن اما
نتنياه فتجاهل الحديث عن الاقتحام في جلسه
الحكومه وفضل التحدث عن ايران
الاتفاق النووي الخطير شطب عن طاوله البحث
بعد الاحداث الاخيره في ايران اعتقد بان
هذه الامكانيه ما زالت قائمه ولم تنتهي في
حكومه فيها لن تكون هناك تفرقه عنصريه
اليهود سيصعدون لجبل الهيكل ونوضح لحماس
اننا لن نتراجع وفي العوده الى الاقتحام
فان بين كبير سبق وان تسبب بالحرب الاخيره
على قطاع غزه بعد اقتحاماته متكرره لساحات
الاقصى وحي الشيخ جراح لكن الاقتحام
الحالي يبدو مغيرا بعد ان اصبح في موقع
صنع قرار يعرف بن كبير في اسرائيل بانه
مشعله حرائق تقليديه وقد وضع حاليا بالقرب
من برميل من البارود واقتحامه للمسجد
الاقصى سيصب الزيت على نار المواجهه مع
الفلسطينيين الذين يقولون بان التطرف لم
يعد تصريحات او شعارات وان ممارسه على
الارض زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الشرقيه
المحتله
اظهرت صور متداوله ادرام محتاجون النار
محتاجين النار في سوره قائد فيلق القدس
التابع للحرس الثوري في طهران ومدينه
مراغه بمحافظه الشرقيه
[موسيقى]
هذه صور مباشره من جديد لمجلس النواب
الامريكي في اول جلسه منذ الانتخابات
ويعني هناك عمليه تصويت على انتخاب رئيس
للمجلس من الجمهوريين الخلاف شاسع ونرى
عدد من عوائل الاعضاء الكونجرس موجودين
يبدا انه بالجلسه الاولى يكون هناك افراد
من عائله اعضاء الكونجرس من الاطفال او
حتى من اذا من افراد العائله ان ياتوا الى
جانب هؤلاء باول جلسه لهم همم ويعني من
المستبعد ان يصل مكارسي الى الموقع اليوم
اقله في هذا التصويت لكن طبعا نتابع مع
مراسلينا من 28 سنه
وفي نشره المساء ولكن بعد قليل
حلم السفر يتحول الى كابوس اعشاب البحر
تقبض على سفينه ركاب لي ثمانيه ايام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لا تمرضوا ولا تسافروا
اذا كان
بامكانكم ذلك هكذا يناشد المسؤولون
البريطانيون المواطنين بلادهم فما استمرار
تضعيات اضراب الممرضين الاخير وارتفاع
اصابات الانفلونزا طلب رؤساء ومسؤولون
الصحه البريطانيين بالابتعاد عن مراجعه
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه في حل لم تكن
الحاله المرضيه سيئه وعلى الجانب الاخر من
الاضراب
السوق الفتح او استنى فات اضرابات وسائل
النقل في بريطانيا
الاضرابات اليوم بعدما احدثت اضطرابات في
الحركه خلال فتره الاعياد حيث يخطط عمال
السكك الحديد البالغ عددهم نحو 40 الف
يخططون لخمسه ايام من الاضراب
[موسيقى]
مصطفى زارو ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه من
لندن مصطفى الاضراب بالقطارات مترو
الانفاق تاثر ما هي الخيارات امام
المتنقلين داخل بريطانيا هل الباص شغال
الحفلات في هذا الوقت تعمل بشكل جيد ولكن
القطارات يعني قطار واحد من بين كل خمس
قطارات
متوقفه حاليا هناك ما يقارب من 40 الف
عامل كما ذكرت يعني يضربون عن العمل على
مدى خمسه ايام ولكن لربما يوم الخميس
سيشهد ربما
اضطراب اكبر في حركه التنقل بعد ان اعلن
همم اعضاء نقابه نقابه عمال السكك
الحديديه وخاصه السائقين انهم سيضربون عن
العمل وهذا سيؤثر بشكل كبير على همم
مواصلات بين المدن وحتى داخل المدن
الكبيره همم حاليا اتواجد في محطه على خط
اليزابيث وهو خط حديث تم انشاءه من
المحطات التي تضررت لكن في الثانيه عشر من
هذا الشهر هؤلاء الذين يعملون في هذا الخط
سيضربونا على العمل وبالتالي ستكون هذه
المحطه مغلقه تماما بعض المحطات في مترو
الانفاق همم شهيده تاخيرا او حتى في بعض
الاجزاء الرحلات معلقه بسبب هذا الاضراب
لان تعرفين بان سكك الحديد تتشارك في بعض
الاحيان مع مترو الانفاق ولكن معظم
القطارات داخل همم العاصمه همم لندن تعمل
وان كانت هناك بعض التاخيرات وبالتالي همم
يعني لازلنا نرى حركه وان كانت بطيئه لكن
هناك مناشده كما ذكرت من قبل المسؤولين
همم
بتفادي اخذ القطارات وخاصه في في ايام
الاضراب بسبب الطلب الكبير وبسب قله
القطارات في هذه المرحله
نظام صحي يعود مره ثانيه يعني خلال
السنوات الماضيه دائما ما نشهد مناشده
وضغط كبير على قطاع الصحه ولكن يبدو بعد
فيروس كورونا يبدو ان القطاع هو تحت ضغط
كبير لم يشهد مثله من قبل منذ تسعينيات
القرن القرن الماضي بالرغم من المليارات
التي تطخها في هذا القطاع ولكن يعني كيف
شخص يمكن ان يحدد او يخطط لمرض ماء في وقت
ما هذا صعب بالطبع خصوصا ان في فصل الشتاء
يعني هناك العديد من الامراض الشتويه خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالانفلونزا والعدد يتصاعد
يوميا هناك ما يقابل من 14,000 مريض الان
يخدعون لعلاجات في مختلفيات مصطفى مراد
انت وفريق العمل يعطيك الف عافيه من لندن
مصطفى
في استراليا موني على السفينه سياحيه من
الرسو على سواحلها بسبب وجود نمو فطريه
على هيكل السفينه وذلك وفقا البيانات
الصادره عن السلطات الاستراليه وبالتالي
تبقى السفينه التي تحمل 1000 سائح عالقه
في البحر منذ ثمانيه ايام
[موسيقى]
فيما تواعد الصين بالرد على الاجراءات
المتخذه بحق مواطنيها بشان كورونا قالت
رئيسه وزراء الفرنسيه ان قال رئيس الوزراء
الفرنسي ان الحكومه تؤدي واجبها
الاختبارات الطبيه للمسافرين القادمين من
الصين
كان ممكن
تؤدي الحكومه واجبها في حمايه الفرنسيين
من خلال طلب الاختبارات المسافرون من
الصين الى فرنسا يتعهدون بقبول اجراء
الاختبار عند وصولهم ما يساعدنا في الحصول
على بيانات حول تطور الفيروس والتاكد من
وجوده نفعل ذلك مع احترام كامل لقواعد
منظمه الصحه العالميه وصالون وصل
[موسيقى]
عرض الاتحاد الاوروبي على الصين تثبيتها
بلقحات مجانيه مع ارتفاع عدد الاصابات
هناك بعد تخفيف البيكين سياستها صفر»
واوضح متحدث باسم المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان
الصين لم ترد بعد على العرض الاوروبي هذا
ولم يتحدث او يحدد المتحدث كميه اللقاحات
التي عرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي في على الصين
او الشركات المصنعه لها
نشرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست تقريرا اشارت فيه
الى زياده عمليات البحث على جوجل عن صلاه
الالعاب الرياضيه مع بدايه العام الجديد
مضيحه اهم الخطوات لتكريس اعاده ممارسه
الرياضه
[موسيقى]
ختام ونشره المساء الى العناوين
بايس 19
للفريق السعودي تحديا جديدا
[تصفيق]
تحت
وللمره الاولى منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
القوه الجويه الامريكيه 101 تناول على
اعتاب روسيا
بعدين
قسم والجمهوريون يتوعدونه بقائمه تحقيقات
جنائيه وادنيه
في بريطانيا القطارات ومشلوله بسبب
الاضراب وقطاع الصحه ينازع ويطالب السكان
بان لا يمرضه
المساء والان الى العربيه 360 مع زميل
طاهر بركه مساء الخير مساء الخير
لكريستيانو رونالدو الى الرياض اضافه الى
التصعيد الكبير في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيا